we are continuing our look at taking
grafts and transforming them and
thinking of them in visual terms but as
you can see by the pictures you got
sitting in front of you we're kind of
amping it up a little bit so far we've
looked at can you actually help me
remember what kinds of things do we know
how to do if you know what f of X looks
like what kinds of ways do you know how
to transform that in takers if you okay
so you could do the reciprocal so that's
this guy right I heard square e right so
that's this guy what do we have a look
at yesterday the square root right so we
had a look at this and we also had a
look at what happens when you've got not
y equals but when you've got Y squared
which basically means you just um I'll
put it another color you're basically
getting both the top and the bottom
version of this guy right even simpler
than that though by the way if you think
back a little bit we just had a look at
even simpler ones like this what is that
- if you knew what f of X look like what
would this look like it's a reflection
which way yeah it's a it's it's left to
right so it's across the y-axis how
would I flip it what would I do
algebraically if I wanted to flip the
other way yeah the minus would hang out
the front like so okay so we have all
these different varieties but what they
all share in common is that you're just
looking at one function and you'll just
want to find that as you can see we are
not modifying just one function here
right so this is a little bit like do
you remember what we're doing addition
and subtraction of different graphs
right well we're going to set it to the
next level this is multiplication okay
yeah the reason why it's kind of like we
should hit pause on addition and
subtraction do all of this all this
stuff and now we look at multiplication
is because some of the very important
points that we looked at for
multiplication sorry for reciprocals for
squaring all that they end up being
important here as well so here's what
we're gonna do right I'm you need a
ruler for this so if anyone doesn't have
a ruler right now stick your hand up
because you'll need one
[Music]
yeah why explain anyway that's what I'm
reaching them positive and negative
correct that's exactly why it's just the
top part that was yeah okay so what
you're gonna need your rule of four is
and in the question itself on the page
actually recommends you do this but it's
such a good advice
wait you don't take it we're going to
draw a series of vertical lines on to
here now I'm just going to advise you
know if you have other colors please use
them but if you've all only got a
highlighter which gives you other colors
it's probably gonna be too thickened
it's just gonna make you graph too busy
that's just what I found in the past so
what I'd love you to do is if you've got
another colored pen or if you just have
a pencil do this nice and lightly I'm
gonna change I have a really light
colored color that I can choose so I'm
going to use that but what we're gonna
do is choose some important values and
put some vertical lines on there that
can help us okay now before we even do
that I'm actually going to use the
vertical line that's already on there
because your graph starts with a
vertical line and that is the what kind
of a going to choose that's the y-axis
right so let's have a look at the
vertical line going through there you
can see you've got G of X this parabola
and f of X is straight line right so
what I want to do is just take one value
the Y value and multiply it by the other
one so I've got one multiplied by
negative one what's the product of those
two numbers negative what great let's
just Chuck that in there okay that's the
only vertical line I have at the moment
so now I'm going to put on a few others
to help me out so for example if you
would with me put your ruler up against
x equals one x equals one so that's kind
of here yeah okay so here's where I put
x equals one and you might want to do
that lightly in pencil now the reason
why I'm looking at x equals one is one
of the functions has a very important
value you remember before we were
squaring taking square roots reciprocals
there are important values what's the
important value that the straight line
takes for this value of x the straight
line where is it at it's a y equals
an x equals 1 y equals 0 why might that
be important when I'm not applying I'm
multiplying right I'm doing f of X times
G of X go anything times 0 is 0 so I
actually don't care what this thing is
up here if one of the graphs is equal to
0 then 0 times that will be 0 so I've
got another point that I go through okay
now yeah question what no yes
okay cool I'm gonna keep going I'm gonna
draw another vertical line I'm gonna ask
you to draw 1 through x equals 2 like so
yeah it is cheating sorry but I'm gonna
do it anyway because faster for you to
see what's going on now have a look at x
equals 2 again I'm gonna ask for that
straight line what Y value am i getting
here can you read across that's that's y
equals 1 right so what else is important
about 1 well 1 times something else is
that other something else right 1 times
what does that look like to you it's
between five and six yet let's call five
and a half one times five and a half is
five and a half so I'm gonna go up there
like so okay now I'm starting to get a
bit of a shape here I could start to
join these just by coincidence I've got
x equals zero x equals one x equals two
right it starts to get a little bit
tricky where you go across but not that
impossible if I go across to the other
direction he is x equals negative one
because you actually have a graph that's
accurate here right we've provided we've
supplied the graph for you you can read
off those values can you see them if I
like this in another color there's a
value right there and another one down
there one of those Y values look like
those red dots two and two and negative
two right and you can tell me what the
product of two and negative two is it's
negative four so you're all the way down
and thankfully we have that point right
here like so now at this point because
of the scale that I have available to be
available to me I think I've pretty much
got all the points that I I'm going to
like go further up if I wanted more do
Tail I could for example you can draw as
many vertical lines as you like right so
for example I could draw another
vertical lines sort of halfway between
wanted to like so right now just because
this is a first example yet has to go
through both graphs because what I'm
trying to do is multiply the value of
one graph by the value of the other okay
now by the way just a quick comment you
might see up the top here the title of
this is graphing polynomials by
multiplying ordinates there you know
what a polynomial is right like an x
squared and X cubes or even just an X
right what it it this is actually a word
worth writing you have some space up the
top here I'm gonna get rid of all this
there we go
when you've got x and y coordinates X
comma Y right we call these coordinates
right well the x value and the y a they
actually have names the Y value is what
we see here the Y value is called an
ordinance this guy over here the x value
we care about its own little this is
actually not even in the course but I'm
going to tell you what it is anyway
because for the sake of completeness
it's a weird word it's called an AB
scizor I don't know why it's called that
someone can go and dig up the etymology
for that if you hi assume it's like
Latin or something like that
but we never talked about it which is
what you never have heard this word
before it's not of much importance to us
we're constantly focusing on these Y
values the ordinates right so sorry just
to come back to your question why does
my vertical line always go through both
graphs I need to see where the ordinate
is for both graphs because then those
are the numbers that I'm multiplying
okay now I'm gonna have to try and I
have all this but that looks to be like
about a half right and that looks to me
about three and a half I mean I'm
probably not exactly but half of three
and a half is like 1.6 1.7 so I just
want to put in another one of those new
exercise I've got I've got quite a lot
of certainty over where this graph is
going do you think you could join those
dots now you don't have a go see what
you get I'll give you a second I won't
spoil it just yet
go ahead and join the dots best you can
yeah if you want put in as many in
between as your life I've deliberately
put this color in it's not very clear
because I'm actually really bad when
I've got a particular set of points
these crosses right I'm really bad at
just cleanly drawing one line straight
through it's really hard to do
accurately right so what I've done is
yeah sorry sorry drew no those red
points there with the ordinates of the
original functions and then I multiply
this together to get my new ones okay
Rasim add this curvature here yeah
that's really good question okay so I
put a curve in because the first thing I
noticed is if you look at all of your
blue points you can't draw a straight
line through all of them can you they're
not collinear is our word okay
so therefore if it's not straight there
has to be some curvature now this leads
me to my next point right how do I know
it curves in this way like so okay well
it's for the sake of it let's put one
more vertical line and I'm going to put
it in here
okay like so now this is a tricky putt
so I want you to look closely at this
right I'm gonna zoom in as far as I can
so it's uh it's this one right here it's
the one which doesn't have an X on it
just yet okay so what you can see is if
you have a look at this value here that
looks like negative 1/2 to me ish but
more importantly see this one up here
right even though I don't know precisely
where it is
I know it's bigger than one do you see
that it's bigger than one so if you
multiply by a number by something bigger
than one it gets it gets bigger doesn't
it if I multiply by something like 1.2
or 1.3 whatever number you start with
whether it's 10 or negative 1/2 or
whatever it'll get bigger right if you
multiply by something that's beneath one
it'll get smaller okay but all of these
values are above 1 do you see that so
see this value here if I'm multiplying
by a value bigger than 1 it's gonna get
bigger right this is negative though so
bigger actually means downward does that
make sense so rats and that's how I know
this sort of curves down just a teeny
bit not much but if I drawn it above it
would kind of like wiggle around many
times to pass through all my points so
that's how I know it goes underneath
that's a really good question so Sean
asked like you know you you might not
get a grid in the exam and I should
point out you don't have a grid here
either but you've got enough information
on the axes so sort of infer a grid even
if one is not there and if you need to
honestly
draw draw a very quick rough grid on
there so you can know for the important
values like 1 negative 1 0 at those
kinds of things you need to know where
those are
once I have gone through I was just
saying like I find it hard to draw one
line through once I've kind of feathered
this in with pencil then I'm when I'm
ready I'll say okay I'm ready to put one
clean line through there in pen and
that's the thing that can be seen
clearly you can distinguish it for your
working because once in pen and once in
pencil and also as a bonus in the HSC
they scan this stuff and a scan will
come up nice and clearly ok